grab his xbox controller to play through
a giant holographic portal into a 3d
Minecraft world right on the wall even
though I don't have a hololens I'm able
to play together with sacks from my
surface are you gonna come join my game
Lydia I'm in now I see you jumping
around one of the cool things about
hololens is that it lets you display
Minecraft virtually anywhere you can get
different perspectives on your Minecraft
world it's awesome to play with the
controller but could we show them
something new saks sure let's take our
experience off the wall and then put it
on the table over here create world
I see Lydia way up there as I run around
her face sags can easily navigate and
manipulate the world using his voice and
his hands he can walk around the
hologram pan around four different
viewpoints and even look inside
let's follow Lydia around for a bit
follow player I can zoom in and out for
a better perspective closer all the way
in close-up what are you up to Lydia
I'm hopping in a minecart let's take a
ride down to the village we're gonna
pick a different perspective overview
it's incredibly cool down minecraft on
your table imagine seeing your own world
like this
isn't it crazy that I see Sachs just
standing at the table but through the
hololens he can see a whole Minecraft
universe at his fingertips you can even
raise the entire world and see things
that are normally hidden way underneath
the ground could you give us a sneak
peek of what's under that village sacks
sure
grab the world lift it up let's see
what's hiding underneath Lydia loo huge
stronghold right underneath I'm gonna
mark that for you Mac that you're gonna
have to find a way to break in I see it
I'm on my way there now I'm placing some
TNT so I can blow my way into this
stronghold I could use a light those
sacks good strategy using hololens I
have access to all console commands and
minecraft just using my boys but I can
just focus my gaze on the TNT and say
lightning strike step back blow there's
a lot of materials down there I wouldn't
have seen without you one more thing I
want to do with lightning see you Pigpen
over here
I think the pigs need an upgrade
lightning strikes there you have it
zombie Pigman
from playing Minecraft on your wall to
an entire world